-So, I want to talk
about some good news.
Boris Johnson,
out of the woods.
-Yes. Yes.
-The Queen actually
gave an address.
This is very rare.
-Yes.
-Was it a tonic
for you to see the Queen speak
-I mean, what kind of tonic?
One of those tonics that you
think is going to do something
you rub it on you,
and you realize,
"Oh, no, that didn't do it"?
-Yeah. [ Laughs ]
-Like an expensive tonic,
like something from Goop,
where you just go --
-Yeah, or maybe like
a gin and tonic,
but the tonic's a little flat.
-[ Laughs ]
That's exactly it.
-Okay, gotcha.
-You know, 'cause normally the
Queen speaks every Christmas
And if the Queen is speaking
at a time that isn't Christmas
it's not because
things are going well.
-It's because Princess Diana
just died,
or the country is at war.
-Right.
-That's basically it.
So, the Queen turning up
in itself
is not a reassuring thing.
If it's a message from the Queen
and it's not
"Happy Christmas, everyone,"
then that's not great.
And so, yeah, I hope, for thos
whom she could calm down,
I hope she calmed them down.
But I don't know if --
We said on our show,
what was more inspiring
was that she was wearing
a green dress,
and so everyone in England
just started projecting things
onto the green dress.
-Oh, because
it was a green screen.
It was a natural green screen.
-Yeah, it was a green screen
So, you should never wear gree
in front of a television camer
unless you're happy
to have things --
unless you're happy to wea
things that people
want you to wear.
And that's -- In a sense,
the Queen learned
a very important lesson,
which is if you don't want
to be dressed like Iron Man,
don't wear a green dress.
-So you don't think this was a
case of her knowing in advance
like, "Let them -- They'll
have some fun with this"?
-That would be great.
-[ Laughs ]
-I mean, it would be
wildly out of character,
but it would be
very generous, right?
-Like someone choosing a movie
poster
that's begging for a [bleep]
to be drawn on it.
-[ Laughs ]
God, I've never been
much of a monarchist,
but I would really appreciate,
like, her coming to the nation's
time of need.
She goes, "No, I don't
want to go with the blue.
Give them the green."
-Yeah. "Let them
enjoy themselves."
-"Let them enjoy --
Have at it, Britain."
[ Both laugh ]
"This country is at war
with a vicious disease.
Have at it."
-[ Laughs ]
One of the people
that's reassuring
or certainly has brought
some reassurance to many
is Dr. Anthony Fauci.
-Yeah.
-Some say, "How can you stan
there if you're a doctor
and listen to the presiden
say things
that we know are
scientifically untrue?"
But you actually have
some appreciation
for the tough spot he's in
-Yeah. I mean, yeah.
I think, when he was
asked a question,
that question,
by a medical journal,
I think his response was, right,
"What would you have me do?"
'cause I get, you could have him
just cough "Bull[bleep]"
or into your sleeve,
not into your hand.
-[ Laughs ]
-"Bull[bleep]. Bull[bleep]
But, yeah, but that would mean
that he couldn't
do his job anymore,
and I think there's
nothing more important
than him doing his job
as long as he possibly can
And so he's going to need
to draw on internal
reserves of discipline
that I certainly
don't have access to.
-No, we're very lucky
not to be in a situation
where we have to nod along
with people we disagree with
-That's right. His biggest tel
is just kind of slightly -
just doing that.
-[ Laughs ]
-Rather than just the full
"What the [bleep]"
-It's like he's slowing down
a face slap.
Like a --
-That's right. That's right.
Just --
Not just the full, "Oh, God.
-[ Laughs ]
-"I'm so good at my job.
How can he be so bad at his?
-Thank you so much
for making time for us.
I really appreciate it.
Thanks for doing your show
through all this.
-Congratulations to Alexi
on the flower arrangements
It's nice to see.
-Thank you.
And I know
as soon as this is over
you re-scrub those walls to keep
them that way, and you're --
[ Both laugh ]
-Full "Karate Kid." Wax on -
Wipe on.
-Thanks, John.
-Wipe off.
-We'll see you back
in the studio next time, I hope.
-[ Chuckles ]
Sure, I'll see you in 2021
-[ Laughs ]
John Oliver, everybody.